what is this father of yours was he a
good musician what did he play I mean he
was a great musician he was my father
was really talented I mean he just he
just blew every chance he had I think he
was one of those guys that was very
insecure and so every time he did have
an opportunity he'd blow it with drugs
or whatever he just he would just blow
it he's just one of those people but he
was very talented did he ever come to
you looking for uh money or like doing
oh he stole money from me multiple times
really
as you got more famous and had money you
ever have ever told you the story about
the lottery no so my father had come out
of jail and he was living in some sort
of drug Den underneath the train tracks
in Chicago like the L like you know it's
like the worst place to live underneath
the tracks right and we had some
occasional contact but it was very very
distant
and one day he called me and said can I
take you out to dinner sure he showed up
new clothes new car
and I said uh did you rent this car
and he laughed and said sorta
and then I kept hearing from relatives
did your dad win the lottery
and I said no but it got so pervasive
that I eventually finally texted him and
said did you win the lottery and he said
call me
his wife's aunt had won the Florida
State Lottery 27 million dollars clean
was the only winner
so he and his wife went from a drug Den
to being set up and being taken care of
for the rest of their lives wow but my
father didn't want me to know because I
would ask him for my money back that he
stole from me so he hid the fact that
his his extended family had won the
lottery so he wouldn't have to pay me
back the thousands of dollars he still
that's like that's how my father's brain
worked